j'ai hyper romantique ouais et une fois
j'étais parti en vacances mon copain
m'avait invité en vacances au soleil fin
mot décembre sa conseillère de peinture
bas non non non pas du tout ça c'était
un peu plus loin c'était tout savoir
ah oui on veut savoir oui les
téléspectateurs va le savoir j'ai invité
ou à madagascar
ah oui quand même et c'était loin
c'était dix jours aux mains des anneaux
el bakouri à 10 jours à noël à
madagascar
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
des gars et je sais que c'est pas
castaldi porte une fois je sais pas ce
n'était plus rien bah non mais je
parcours va concerner la personne a de
l'argent c'est mieux pour vous en savez
quelque chose parce que vous avez retenu
une tête de l'enfant va faire la gueule
[Applaudissements]
ça peut donner des idées à toute la
france
si je raconte leur pleurer tellement
c'était mignon qui veut dire que vous
sortez alors vers 22h30 il me dit viens
sur la plage ballon amoureux c'est
mignon j'arrive sur la plage il avait
écrit tout mon nom donc mathieu avec de
thq delormeau et tous n'ont même pas
tout non non non non pas l'animateur le
prénom le mois oui monsieur
oui juste avec des bougies comme ça
mathieu pédophilie sur la plage à bord
s'est pris la tête à des créatures des
bougies noires
[Rires]
mais c'est pas du tout les murs à
ramener dans la chambre après pour
mettre des la chambre et non en foot ça
c'était un détail c'était parce que
c'est cher tourner des scènes de bouger
c'était bougies cerrito déclaratives à
bois avec des bougies
ouais mais quelle bougies avec des
babouches voilà quoi mais bon c'est une
bonne histoire vous avez chalet pour ça
alors touchant que c'était un début
d'histoire t'es mignon à la
consanguinité renard bon bayer 6 mai